[Music]
[Applause]
Marcellus Wiley the former NFL All-Pro
defensive end host of more to it on The
Dan Patrick Podcast Network this week's
guest is Sean Merriman who talks about
channeling the emotions he had from
growing up homeless into being a great
football player in the birth of Lights
Out here's a clip from Marcellus Wiley
with Sean Merriman
so I was getting some notoriety in the
country and uh they asked me they said
hey why do you um why why do you play
football
and I looked at the guy not having any
media training nothing I said I could do
anything I want to somebody and not go
to jail right so I was like she's like
that for the record yeah I was like I'm
glad they picked that back up because I
would have looked like a psychopath back
then but I think what I was trying to
say as a kid was I was going through a
lot and that was my outlet that was that
was how I got everything off my chest
because that's a two hours of my day
that I didn't have to worry about
everything else that was going on and so
I didn't realize that was uh be me kind
of van out at that time but looking back
on it now was I was just speaking from
what I was going through that's Sean
Merriman the podcast more to it on The
Dan Patrick Podcast network with your
host Marcellus Wiley the former NFL pro
defensive end Sean Merriman had a lot of
energy
oh yes lights out was appropriate in
terms of the way he played I remember
him coming to the San Diego Chargers
after I was abruptly released
um and just saw his immediate impact the
energy he played with uh as he talked
about his emotional content was on full
display every single Sunday because he
had it hard growing up not homeless once
but homeless twice uh a really tough
upbringing that he was able to extract
all of those issues and demonstrate them
on football fields on Sundays
when you look at some of these guys who
have been busted for Peds like Antonio
Gates that's not going to hurt him as a
Hall of Famer right
Antonio Gates uh didn't know that he got
busted did Antonio Gates Get please tell
me that you're wrong on that one I
thought he had it I thought yeah I
thought he had uh a moment where he got
uh suspended four games for Peds oh 20.
oh he crossed this he crossed the state
border for me like like once you're
busted including Rodney Harrison one of
my greatest teammates and dear friends
once you're busted for Peds my respect
for your career goes from wherever it
was to zero just because I can't imagine
a professional athlete that uses his
body as his tool as his tremendous
resource to play the game would resort
to something like that so I don't have
respect for their career I still love
the person I still love Sean Merriman
Gates Rodney Harrison a lot of charges
um I respect all of them as people but
not as players once they get busted yeah
Gates denies it but still he would
suspended for uh for four games I had a
player who used steroids and I said why
would you use steroids he goes because
they work
I can't lie about that you know what
at hindsight if you could have given me
something that would have ensured my
health not enhanced performance I was
big fast and strong I felt confident in
my abilities but if you could have kept
me on the field if there was a wonder
drug a Wonder pill that could have kept
me on the field can't lie to you Dan I
would have took that but anything that
helped me I wasn't about that but a lot
of guys actually say that's the reason
they take it just to stay on the field
but is HGH still a big deal steroids
still a big deal do you think
I think it is
um as we saw with DeAndre Hopkins well
this off season I think it still is the
guys try to stay ahead of the the
testing obviously but how do they
delighted how do you stay ahead uh
that's what the doctors try to promise
these players and they probably have a
high success rate therefore only few
players get busted but there are doctors
out there that will swear to you that if
you take this they won't detect it and
it would help you and those are the
cases we don't identify those aren't the
cases we talk about because those guys
don't get caught well there was always
the Whizzinator
Ontario Smith with the Whizzinator with
the Vikings right yeah I would have told
on him just for being a weird teammate I
was like dude you're doing too much come
catch him the Whizzinator I I love it
that you'll order that online
oh my God I don't know I did I never I
never came close the closest I got to
hghp Peds was at a 24-hour Fitness in
San Diego and some big buff Surfer type
dude who just knew I was with the
Chargers came up to me was like man you
look good you want to look better and I
was like huh and then he was like I got
something for you and I said I got
something for you too Deuces peace sign
but I'm all right all right help me
understand what the Colts are doing
are they tanking
oh obviously they're tanking um but what
are they doing in the process of tanking
they're doing Discovery uh if you use as
an interim head coach Jeff Saturday what
you're telling your guys is one this is
a guy who has a tremendous relationship
with this organization and its owner Jim
ersek with that said I want someone who
knows this situation backwards I want
someone who knows where all the bodies
are buried in this building I want
someone who knows all the secrets I want
someone who knows how to do it right in
Indianapolis now he doesn't have the
resume to support that but he does have
the relationships and he does have the
respect in that building to maybe catch
fire if he doesn't in Failure they still
succeed because they're tanking so it's
really a no lose proposition once you
come to the summation that hey this
season is a wash we've had seven
different starting quarterbacks under
Frank right and it's just not going to
get fixed so now it's time to take our
lumps see what we can find out through
this process about everyone's character
about everyone's production when it
doesn't quote unquote count and now
let's go out there and see if we can do
something if not we're going to find our
savior in this draft we're going to get
one of these quarterbacks and see how we
can go going forward yeah I just don't
understand that you picked Jeff Saturday
he's a good guy
but do I want to make him the head coach
here you have guys on your staff who've
been head coaches before and you're not
going to put them in there you also has
have a quarterback who's won a Super
Bowl on your roster you're not going to
start him you're going to start a guy
who has never played before and Sam
Ellinger I
I I and it feels like Jim irsay thinks
that uh Jeff Saturday is not only there
for this year but for you know ensuing
seasons
yeah you know what's interesting about
this
um to play Devil's Advocate and also to
talk a little bit of Truth to the
situation we always say that Sports is a
meritocracy especially football the
ultimate team sport everyone has to come
in they're all balanced and even from
day one and then you earn your position
that's a damn lie you know why because
everyone that you come in contact with
you already have a understanding of
their abilities or you have in
relationship that you can rely on on top
of a resume that fills in the blanks
let's start there so Jim Mercy looks at
Jeff Saturday and he's like the dude was
a tremendous player for us in our Ring
of Honor you can't say anything bad
about the guy tremendous character and
maybe he's like I'm going to find
lightning in a bottle I'm going to find
someone who can Inspire others because
let's be real Frank Reich had a resume
there are guys on that coaching staff
that have a resume and they fail so if
you're coming from a resume that is
quote unquote successful but the guy is
not successful why not Zig when everyone
else is zagging why not all of a sudden
get into a situation where you're going
to roll the dice on someone that you
believe in uh so you're okay with this
you're okay with this I'm okay with it
because I know the coaching cycle goes
as good resume build yourself up your
work former coordinator you become a
head coach and you fail and then we do
that over and over again
at least we should be open-minded to
inserting someone in there that maybe
doesn't have that pedigree that doesn't
have those relationships in terms of
being at different institutions High
School College Pro but all of a sudden
bam you know why I remember more Mike
Tomlin was hired and people say he
didn't have the proper resume even
though he was an NFL coach they said the
proper resume look at Mike Tomlin I
could take it to my own personal
experiences when people say ah where
he's from or what he's accomplished not
good enough give me an opportunity I
will make something of it I'm not
betting on Jeff Saturday because he's in
a horrible situation but let's be real
any professional coach with a tremendous
resume you put in that situation chances
are they're going to fail why not do
something like that is off the beaten
path and see if it works Marcellus Wiley
the podcast is more to it Dan Patrick
Podcast Network former All Pro defensive
m
Josh Allen's injury we don't know the
extent of it but as a defensive player
how much of that would you
would you factor in when you're facing
the Buffalo Bills with Josh Allen if you
know that that right arm is a little
more sensitive
is that part of the game plan
yes part of the game plan and it's a
play you should never call mentally
because what happens is when you go into
any game compromised in terms of like
I'm thinking this team is less than and
my son and I always talk about this
because he's he's just he's just in a
position where he looks at games and he
bases it off of what their record is so
he's like Daddy Daddy how did the Rams
lose I was like well the Rams are not
good this year but they're the Champs
and I'm like look it's not how good you
are it's how well you play so I look at
this situation if I'm a Defender to not
get caught up in that trap that fool's
gold oh Josh Allen you know what his
elbow hurts his arm hurts he's going to
be 70 80 percent because already you're
given an advantage to the Buffalo Bills
why
it's this simple they say if you lose
one of your senses let's say you lose
your sense of of touch you lose sight
your other senses are enhanced so what
happens in football is that if you're
compromised but can still play
everything else is enhanced because
you're so focused like oh my God I'm
limping through this I gotta have
everything else turned on to a hundred
and if you're a defender of that guy and
he still can play and he's Josh Allen
and you thinking he's less than be
careful brother it could be a rude
awakening but would you rather face
Lamar Jackson or Josh Allen
oh
ah just ah
Josh Jackson
I would rather face Lamar Jackson
because there are going to be plays he
misses every single game despite his
greatness despite how amazing Lamar
Jackson is I watched that game against
the Saints there are at least three
touchdowns left on the field by Aaron
throws well Josh Allen I don't feel that
confident that he will give us those
opportunities Lamar will still give you
opportunities but then also be the human
eraser and make up for those misses
you know you got the Cowboys in Green
Bay
the Packers have lost five in a row
Dallas going in there favored I
it just feels like Green Bay is going to
be Green Bay one of these weekends right
no I just told my son Nick come on Dan
fail oh they were 13-3 the last three
years you know the greatest thing about
football
is that on the field once you step
between the white lines for 60 minutes
it is all earned like nothing's given I
could come off a game where I destroyed
the tackle sacks after sacks after sex
couldn't be blocked get into the next
game against a lesser tackle like a
no-name a fire hydrant people like who
this dude Wally gonna have 20 sacks
nothing absolutely nothing so if you're
the Dallas Cowboys it's a trap game in
the sense of Green Bay is just a uniform
they're just green and gold now they're
not that good Aaron Rodgers his best
days are far behind him he should have
retired he should have left
and then you get into the game and
realize oh they're black belts all
across this field just what degree of
black belt are they and you find out the
hard way so be careful of every game you
play because it's Any Given Sunday who's
the worst tackle you ever win against
I don't know his name because it was
that sorry but uh let me turn
I can say who is the most over hyped
tackle and and and this is going to
sound crazy because I never got a sack
against them but when I heard of what
Jonathan Ogden could do on the field and
then when I went against them I was like
he's a destroyer he's killing me but
there's a way to beat him there's a but
when I I never had the opportunity I
never did it but I was like I'm not
dying out here I'm doing something but
people thought that it was no way no how
around the guy and obviously he gave up
sacks at times but it was just like his
reputation was out of this world I was
like no he's still on planet Earth he's
just probably the best of all us humans
but I know who didn't get enough credit
was Walter Jones like even though I saw
Bruce Smith give him three or four or
five sacks one game Walter Jones was
fast as a receiver and bigger than the
security guard at the club and would
block you no matter what so I always
thought that Ogden's reputation could
come down a notch and Walter Jones his
rep should have went up a notch who are
you talking to next week on the podcast
oh damn this is gonna be fun uh I am
talking to me uh I've been listening to
our audience and they want a lot of
Marcellus talking about me in these Hot
Topics that are circling the sports
world right now so we're going to cross
it up we're going to talk to Kyrie
situation we're going to talk about
what's happening in the NFL right now at
the top and it's upside down
would you want Kyrie as a teammate
no not as a teammate
um I would love to be a fan of him as a
basketball player because I still think
he's the most skilled basketball player
I've ever seen But as a teammate no
because
in his pursuit of being authentic and
having a voice we're getting distant
from why we're here in the first place
which is playing basketball and if I
were his teammate I would say you would
have to do both respectfully
consistently or pick and what we have to
pick is basketball and I think that's
where Kevin Durant is in this situation
he's caught in the tug of war of
respecting the person of Kyrie but also
saying hey dude I need the player of
Kyrie to always show up and that's a
tough place to be if you're KD or a
teammate always great to talk to you
Marcellus thanks for joining us have a
great weekend all right brother talk to
you later Marcellus Wiley former All-Pro
defensive end and uh host of the more to
it podcast